[Music]
welcome to off the record where we talk
about what everyone
what's up silent mike better hey hey
mike
it's been like two years yeah i don't
think i've ever been on jk with you
actually no
hallways and stuff and now the office is
gone completely gone and gutted oh yeah
yeah we have extra parts just randomly
in like a public storage space like all
the studio stuff that we hung off the
ceiling what are you guys gonna do with
it
i don't know we try to sell it and uh
you know it's an old street
we might need a tree we don't have the
tree we have trust systems you know
those triangular oh dude
you want a door you want to buy
something i can't afford it
we have a [ __ ] ton of those those are
worth a ton you could put those on offer
up and those maybe you need to help us
sell it and then we also have like those
keno thingies and we have like 30 of
them oh my god dude oh yeah if you guys
sell it we'll give you a cut
dude
yeah people buy trusses all the time
off-road
well i don't know why we didn't sell art
what's up michael you didn't sell it
yeah [ __ ] mike dude we actually had
uh so michael's in charge of selling
everything and we had some fan art you
remember um
uh like uh i don't know have you been to
that yeah yeah so there was like all
this like like a
comic version of like the whole jk crew
it was huge and then
i guess someone just came and was like
offered michael can i buy this and
michael's like sure or whatever because
we're just need to get out and then
someone tagged me
in a podcast of like these two like
hipster dudes and that was the art and
they don't even know where it's from
they don't even know who we are we're
incredible yeah that's it so you have
like this hipster podcast with like
david and like a camera coming out of
his shoulder it's like me with like a
pacifier in my mouth and it's like just
in the back of him like yes it's cool we
got this like asian burger king kids
my friend went on their podcast and
they're like do you even know who these
guys are they're like nah who are these
guys i don't know they just care to find
out who these guys are because we're
just selling everything so they came in
like what's that how much is that how
much is that and we just sold it they
took everything yeah
dude everyone's got a podcast there's
like a twitch streamer now you could
probably sell the [ __ ] out of those
lights everybody needs background stuff
yeah oh yeah dude they have a section
down at best buy for like tuber stuff
yeah you can go get a ring light and get
your like tuber stuff they're the kits
yeah it's a streaming kit yeah you put
your phone on and there's like a light
on here there's like a little mic a
little fuzzy
it's like one for gamers one for only
fans one for like you you can get like
gift cards it's just followers no way no
just too though that exists have you
seen that documentary uh
not social dilemma but there's another
one where they take like three la cats
and then they make them famous one
it's pretty good yeah we did a podcast
on it and like uh we're talking about
people or animals because uh counts
yeah due to my syntax i think cats
always guess what like a 90s term i
don't know
one of my sisters what are you a jazz
musician one of my assistant coaches he
said it's for all jazz boomers
and what happened all three became
famous no like one like fell under the
pressure one didn't like the morality of
it because they're buying followers and
stuff they really do go into the
psychology that i i mean you guys are
all like ogogs and i'm like a mini og
like i've done it for eight years you
gotta wear that
that's old yeah yeah i'm [ __ ] 34
almost but they uh these dudes like plan
it so well where they're like uh oh you
want a hotel sponsorship we're gonna
fake a hotel in our backyard and they
fake a salon in the backyard tag a fake
or a real one like oh thanks hilton for
having me hilton didn't have him and
then marriott reaches out and it's like
hey come to the marriott for a free it
does work no it [ __ ] it does work
they're doing this we're gonna do this
that's what hollywood does they're like
what do you think we had two uh white
house down we had white house down we
had the other like president right on
the same
[Laughter]
watch what's about to happen too because
ncu and dc are about to do time travel
[ __ ] like like big time like alternate
universe [ __ ] and they're all both doing
it at the same time dc if you need
another shane cheat dude
yeah they haven't supposed to be the
submariner yeah yeah
they're more the submariner
first here's the shane that's maybe semi
i think it's funny homogenous you guys
see the movie have you guys seen the
movie yet i watched it i did not see it
it was good it was good it was fun it
was really good i've had access to a
theater in a minute
so yeah it's theater only right yeah
yeah are only some theaters open they're
all open dude varquan
oh that's a real person i thought you
just made up some random no it's the dc
like he's the dc aquaman he's asian
i'm sorry oh marvel he's the marvel
aquaman marvel aquaman dude submariner
dude that's you man just make the peek a
little bit more
cast me i just found out he exists yeah
that's a good thought he's asian a scaly
underwear he's asian-ish he looks kind
of asian i think so that looks like the
ultimate refugee like you could just
swim from nation to nation
that's a superpower that is an asian
superpower oh no communism again
[Laughter]
and you get the story too because your
dad had to swim
that's your origin story yeah
dude i think you're destined to play
this dude what's that anymore name or
the submariner dude are you super into
comics
are you super into comics i was as a kid
i still i'm mostly just a batman fan now
but but um i like all this all the
marvel dc [ __ ] do you like dc and marvel
i do but i was more of a dc kid growing
up so now i'd probably get my ass kicked
in school but back to bed but back then
you get your [ __ ] ass kicked if you
like marvels
superman batman was the [ __ ] what's your
favorite uh
batman movie that's not christopher
nolan oh i like oh yeah true okay uh i
like batman returns honestly batman
returns let's do it with arnold
oh that's batman robin people [ __ ] on
that that one's sick
mr freeze yeah i love mr freeze dude i
remember the break
but that was for batman forever right oh
man yeah
oh yeah with a seal yeah
it was a bigger track what a great
superhero movie track no the best
probably the
tim burton ones the tim burton batman
batman returns yeah penguin those are
the dark ones that was dumb that's my
favorite urbane is vain in that one
the one that you like that's what's
starting to make that bane sucks though
yeah that that beans yeah
all he needs to do is stays on there
that thanks so much a [ __ ] idiot in
that one huh bain's a really smart guy
from the comics he's smart as [ __ ] he's
a tactician but it didn't top the uh the
joker though no no nothing else yeah
yeah which joker oh the one from from
the new one from justice league joaquin
phoenix oh you want my hot tape yeah
please take it the new new joker which
one the new no
the solo jared leto yeah amazing
joker i was gonna say overrated but
nobody says it
nobody says it's good oh really i
thought everybody loved it no no no no
not suicide squad the one where he's uh
joaquin joaquin joaquin was an oh dude
see i think overrated what do you think
overrated you're a loser no and i got a
bunch of mental health issues so you
think that would just you think that
would be screaming at me it didn't
really no i didn't know why was it
overrated for you because everyone like
everyone loved it like oh he's acting in
the depth of the mental health what kind
of mental health [ __ ] you got oh dude i
i once i've gone to therapy my whole
damn life and then just recently i need
it
dude i hide it well within within like
the last like uh it was like two years
ago just
one session we sat down and i don't know
why but she listed like four things and
i'm sitting there like i felt guy was
being sentenced you know you see like
the court case like murder first degree
third degree she just started listing
like diagnosis yeah well they're like
these shoes like probably stuff she
didn't like officially diagnose it i'm
sitting here what are they uh like adhds
whatever i have that yeah general
anxiety disorder which is like everybody
got that [ __ ] no see they don't they
don't everybody gets anxiety or
everybody gets anxious
everyone gets stressed but general
anxiety disorder is like i don't know
five percent it's like
everything and it doesn't stop is that a
high spectrum
it's like ruminating thoughts anxiety
over everything like is it like
physically debilitating kind of it can
be you see toothpicks and you freak out
freak the [ __ ] out over mint toothpaste
in particular it's all of them
not the cinnamon ones not in particular
uh depression stuff same thing people
get sad or people like go through phases
like even talking to my mom who's super
smartly she's like yeah i get like
depressed for a day but you get really
messed up for weeks and i'm like yeah
mom i do like like just done you know
[ __ ] like that i've known you for a long
time but i've never met you in like a
down state though because i probably
wouldn't come down here that makes sense
you don't want to rub it on everybody
yeah right yeah not only that but then
like uh
when it's bad bad you can't even hide it
you just can't i just you just don't go
out yeah i just disappeared i don't go
out anyways what do you mean you
disappear you just hide in a room yeah
and you just won't come out yeah what
are you doing during that like how do
you get yourself calm and stuff i don't
and the issue is is that like i don't
have a cope and so that's part of my
therapy too like it's like oh do you
drink like not really oh do you do drugs
like not really you i thought working
out
nah not really working i was just like
part of what i do do you like jacking
off
it cures a lot no i hate jacking off
[Laughter]
a lot of people love jack it off
take i'll talk about the joker and
jacking off i hate it
yeah there's six jackets a day will help
you yeah dude but all of those coping
things sound pretty unhealthy though
gambling drugs jersey patrol dude that's
pretty good
took patrol
good recall i think i think all those
things can be unhealthy like obviously
but if you don't have an outlet it's
even unhealthier because then i end up
crash crashing that's like not farting
when you need a fart and you hold it in
you're [ __ ] forever how bad does your
stomach diarrhea sharks yeah your
stomach hurts forever if you released it
it could've just been a fart but you
held it so hard now it's a shark today's
video is brought to you by curology
all right guys i know if you are
anything like me who is a dirty piece of
[ __ ]
you never washed your face with products
and your idea of washing a face is
getting some water and just rinsing
maybe half of your face that's the way
my grandma did it yup and her skin was
ugly
but actually i've been taking care of my
skin these days thanks to curology thank
you very much because uh they made it
very simple for someone like me who
doesn't want to think of all the
different products all of the different
skincare routine it's just too crazy
okay they set up super super simple just
for me they gave me a custom cream that
meets all the goals that i need for
example they have one if you want
something for like acne or if you want
something for anti-aging or if you want
something that's just like gonna keep
your skin tighter or whatever you just
take a quick little survey online and
then you customize
your super duper formula and you get
that formula directly to your door it's
really really easy
so if you're looking to get your skin
routine way more healthier and look
clean and beautiful and youthful and
anti-acne or whatever your goals are go
to curology.com
off the record and get your free
30-day trial
you just gotta pay for shipping and
handling which is only five bucks so go
to curology.com off the record to unlock
your free 30-day trial just pay for
shipping and handling and you can start
your better healthier skin routine now
and it also comes with face wash and a
moisturizer and it comes directly to
your door and on top of that there's a
license provider that helps you out with
this formula too so everything is super
simple and easy to do did they give you
any kind of medication they wanted to
and then i was too scared
they wanted to like hey you want to try
some i was like i don't know
what kind uh anxiety stuff and
depression yeah yeah yeah what makes you
go like i'm just not gonna do medication
i don't know i think one i'm like a
control freak at heart and i don't
that's why i don't really like doing
drugs or drinking like i like to be in
control and know what's going on two
uh i only hear stories like everyone
else does like i don't want it to change
who i am don't do it three is kind of
scary what if you're better maybe you're
100 yeah no 100 percent i could have
been [ __ ] sick i could have been sick
maybe i'd be better at video games and
better at this show
i don't know yeah i think i think those
are the majority of them and then you
always hear all like uh this can cause
more suicide and not eating and always
something like that the side effects are
worse than what's supposed to help you
with yeah you get diarrhea because i've
heard a lot of people love it too same
with even like adhd meds i've heard adhd
like real adhd affects your emotions a
lot more than they talk about and dudes
obviously have a lot more adhd than
ladies yeah there's a power lifter i
don't i don't want me in his name but he
was talking to him to me and he's like
dude i was like a mess like emotionally
he's like and it was just adhd i got him
like adderall or something he's like
that was [ __ ] amazing what's
emotionally a mess like you're just mood
swings yeah i think so yeah yeah like
like like like mini bipolar is
everyone's self diagnosing right now as
he's listening
i'm like [ __ ] do i have it too wait
that's coping too that's coping too
that's coping too oh [ __ ]
that's why i say everybody got
everything man yeah i think so
everyone's obviously [ __ ] up but once
you go to therapy and you start to like
dig into your [ __ ] yeah i think there's
a spectrum though and that's probably
what you know for sure yeah it's like
you're either manic depressed or super
depressed or you just go through going
through a depressive stage or like a
phase yeah yeah like like you said you
have depressed like people can get
depressed but then you don't have
depression right or or like bad [ __ ]
happens some people just have a [ __ ]
life like yeah you're going to be sad if
you have a [ __ ] life like duh does
therapy help if you've been going your
whole life i think
uh i don't know i i i didn't i haven't
got like my whole life straight it's
like patches you know but like um
something if you've been going the same
chiropractor for like 10 years like
maybe this guy
[Laughter]
nobody nobody's ever like fixed from
therapy like oh i'm good now or the best
is this the therapist who's like oh well
you know what's going on you have a [ __ ]
life
real bad
yeah i'd be sad too i think
chiropractors are overrated too dude
some of them some of them are [ __ ]
quacks yeah they're all quacks some of
them straight up crooks man
some of them are quacks but some work
really good well they always shout after
king bro the way that they can pop you
and [ __ ] is incredible it does feel good
but then when they write you like a note
for work that's like you know oh yeah
he's all [ __ ] up it's like really wait
are ezzy though bro some some
chiropractors like they go out of their
scope though they try to like give you
therapy and [ __ ] like they try to do all
that stuff yeah yeah because they're all
holistic they give you tonic water yeah
yeah bro they give you sprays and [ __ ]
they try to tell you like oh you you eat
sugar then your hip flexors don't work
and they do all these muscle tests
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this who's
falling for this
there there are some chiropractors i
follow they started jumping in like you
know like the huge debates about like
covenant and stuff with like phd
researchers md guys right and they're
definitely going here they're in the
same field and there's chiropractors
jumping in and i'm like bro just shut
the [ __ ] up this wasn't your
conversation
you're like you gotta break your back
man uh you know what they say they say
it's gonna detoxify your liver they say
that type of you need to detoxify sugars
the devil they say all kind of nonsense
bro my favorite chiropractor was my
mom's and i don't know why she loved
going there because this is the
crackiest of all the quacks and it's so
much to the point where it was a joke
when i brought geo there for the first
time just i was like it's first of all
it's not gonna work whatever you're
looking to heal is not going to work but
the experience is really cool so this is
what he does when you go there it
doesn't matter what you tell them
because i've been there for all kinds of
injuries it could be your shoulder your
knee or your foot he goes okay i know
what's going on so you don't even have
to tell me and i'll tell you what's
causing the pain so he sits you down and
he goes like this he moves your chin he
goes you see that
and he goes like this you see this
he goes that's why because your ankle is
[ __ ] up so it causes your hip to your
knee and then he'll like as he stated
because i've been there so much with my
mom when he was fixing geo i'm like i'm
trying i'm like trying to finish the
sentences for him he goes how do you
know all this stuff i'm like
i don't know it just seems what you're
saying is so logical
you know what uh rikki is
your guy's reaction is two miles from me
that means you've all been in la too
long
yeah you guys are like ricky yeah yeah
it's not bad some are good some are bad
it's the most normal normalized [ __ ]
living in la you get all this stuff yeah
what's reiki yeah we don't like rub you
with crystals to change my energy dude
there's a whole store no it's like
chiropractory it's like right here next
to chiropractors it's like no contact
cairo it's like
it's like the panda express of qigong
because basically
so it's effective it works
it's like they combined all these asian
things and then they gave it a japanese
name and then they made it this
this weird thing feng shui can be some
[ __ ] too
no that [ __ ] works
short right
exactly that detox my liver
sometimes i walk in the room they're
like i'm like this is really sick and
like it's punctuated and then sometimes
i got you see pen and teller did a
[ __ ] thing where they got a bunch of
uh feng shui people and they all had
different philosophies different things
was completely [ __ ] it's all
subjective she's making it up
yeah it's fantastic yeah one of the
biggest feng shui no-no's is supposed to
be like as soon as you open the door you
shouldn't have your staircase there or
something like that because your life's
gonna end yeah my entire entire
neighborhood
all the houses when you open the door
you see the staircase and you know that
i'm like everyone's gonna end here they
save that door it's gonna lose all your
money right and i made the most [ __ ]
money living in the house with a
staircase
my parents always say like don't put
your bed by the window because then it's
like bad energy or some [ __ ] but
my whole childhood [ __ ] bed right
here where else could you put it yeah my
my room's got like only windows that's
like what yeah that's like what rich
people say yeah
i was like what
i was like there's literally no other
one don't put the toilet in the bathroom
that means you're gonna die in 20 years
do that
my friend lived with the uh feng shui
master he he rented a little room in his
back you know somebody feng shui people
yeah l.a dude
where are these feng shui people he was
like saying basically um i was like man
i can't sleep i don't know what to do
and he's like
how's your room dry draw it out for me
so i drew out my bed everything he goes
it's because you're not facing west yeah
dude that's another one i'm like what do
you mean he goes yeah you know like
people they get um i guess like they're
buried going north or whatever and you
gotta be facing west and i was like all
right
and then i [ __ ] changed it and i was
able to sleep like a [ __ ] no no
i don't know
see that's cured my insomnia dude yeah
maybe it's in here yeah a little placebo
hell yeah
to me i'm not against placebo if it
won't work
especially feng shui where like what
i've got to move my desk around like
there's no negative there's no name okay
i'm moving around if i could eat an m m
and it cures my cancer [ __ ] it dude like
cairo or ricky if i'm [ __ ] paying 150
dollars twice a week to get rubbed with
a purple crystal yeah that's the
negative
it's an amethyst
purple crystal what if you sleep so good
like you've never slept before and
you're like all right i'm paying 150
bucks for this purple crystal [ __ ]
what's the draw of the crystals like
they're expensive yeah like i think
there is something real with crystals
where it is like a conductor yeah and so
i think that they just started
stretching it yeah like you can run you
can run electricity through a crystal
and so i think they just started
stretching that like i can run it
through me to you wow i just need those
balance bracelets that they sell at the
mall and i'll be playing dude remember
those yeah i think they got sued
the sacramento kings entire arena was
power balanced oh [ __ ]
and then i think they got two and then
they switch names new business
opportunities power balance barbell
brigade bracelets i mean they still do
it uh golfers wear that kind of stuff
and baseball players what i see a lot of
baseball players
they say copper the red bracelets have
you seen it the red string bracelets
yeah what is that dude that shit's like
a hundred bucks
a lot of celebrities are [ __ ] wearing
it now yeah what is it supposed to do
like look keep away bad energy or
something
yeah it's a hundred dollars
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you